we are on problem number 14 see what do
they draw here that's the y-axis that's
the x-axis they drew a line that looks
something like this see from negative 3
look something like this well that's
close enough and then they're saying
this is the point negative 3 this is the
point y equals negative 1 this is of
course the y-axis this is the x-axis the
figure above shows the graph of the line
of y equals MX plus B where m and B are
constants which of the following best
represents the graph of y is equal to
minus 3 MX plus B well this is if this
yellow line let me do it this is y
equals MX plus B y is equal to MX plus B
well what is B first of all be is just
the y intercept so the y-intercept is
right here y equals negative 1 so b is
negative 1 and what's the slope well we
when we run that's what one two three
units change in X is 3 change in X is 3
what is the rise the rise we go down so
it's negative 1 we go down one so change
in Y is equal to negative 1 so the slope
is negative one third so the equation of
this line is y is equal to minus one
third X minus one right so if you want
to know what minus three MX plus B is
what's minus three times this M what's
minus 3 times positive x minus one third
well the negatives cancel out so you
just get let me switch to purple because
that's that problem minus three times
this is M right this is am so minus
three x minus one third that just equals
one right so it equals 1 X plus B what's
be its minus one so the graph we're
looking for is X minus one and so if we
wanted to draw that the y intercept
would be the same would be right there
and then you just have a slope of 1
slope of one looks well that's as close
as I could do to drawing it right that's
a slope of 1 your change in X should be
the same as your change in Y slope of 1
so out if you look at all the choices
first of all it's pretty obvious it's d
I think and they make it very explicit
that the slope is 1 and the y intercept
is negative 1 so that's choice D next
problem I get excited when there's
something to draw it's like can we can
get through them faster 15 if the volume
of a cube is 8 so volume is 8 what is
the shortest distance from the center of
the cube to the base of the cube
fascinating so the volume is 8 so what
is this what are the dimensions of this
cube 2 cube so all the sides are the
same right x/x x so x times X times X is
x to the third and that equals 8 so the
dimensions what to the third power is 8
you should know that two right two times
two times two is eight so the dimensions
of the cube are two by two by two so
let's take out that cross section where
the center is let's take that cross
section where the center is right if we
take that that cross section right there
where the center of the cube is and if I
were to draw it so that's just that's
the center of the kids so the center of
the cube is right here and we know the
dimensions of this cross section it's 22
22 right I just slice the cube right
there and then I just want make sure I'm
doing this problem from the center of
the cube to the base of the cube so the
base of the cube is the base of the cube
is going to be right if we if I were to
draw the cube to sort of in the base of
the cube down here so this this is the
base of the cube right so they're
essentially just asking us what's this
distance right here well that's easy
this is the center so it's right in the
middle so it's one all right it's one to
the bottom it's one to the roof of the
cube it's one to each of the sides so
it's one away so that is answer a
next problem image problem 1616 if Y is
equal to 5x cubed over Z what happens to
the value of y when both x and z are
doubled x and z are doubled so what the
way i think about it is y is equal to 5x
the cubed divided by z actually do with
the very the very easiest way to do this
problem is substitute numbers for X and
Z so let's say that x is equal to 1 and
z equals to 1 so in this situation y is
equal to what five times 1/5 I start
five times 1 cubed 5 times 1 cubed
divided by 1 well that's just equal to 5
now they're saying what happens if x and
z are doubled so let's take the second
situation x is equal to 2 z is equal to
two now y is equal to 5 times 2 cubed
over 2 and that is equal to what well to
cube divided by 2 this 2 cancels with
the cubed right and you get 2 squared so
it's just 5 times 2 squared which is
five times four which is 20 so y went
from five to 20 so y increased by a
factor of four so and that is choice e y
is x 4 if these questions can be
surprisingly confusing because you're
like all you have these variables do you
make x into 2 X and Z 2 Z and then solve
for you just try out numbers they're not
putting any restrictions on you so just
substitute x and y x and z you know 11
and then mm next problem the s80 speed
matters more than maybe rigor all right
problem 17
Luke purchase an automobile for $5,000
$5,000 Luke purchase an automobile and
the value of the automobile decreased by
eight by twenty percent per year the
value in dollars of the automobile in
years from the date of the purchase is
given by the function V where V of n is
equal to V of n is equal to five
thousand times four fifths or that's a
foot sorry four-fifths which is anything
is point eight to the nth power fair
enough how many years from the date of
the purchase will the value of the
automobile be thirty two hundred dollars
well they're saying the value is thirty
two hundred dollars so we just solve for
n V of how many years is equal to thirty
two hundred dollars so 30 to 100 is
equal to five thousand times four fifths
to the N divide both sides by five
thousand you get 3,200 over 5,000 is
equal to four fifths to the N and then
let's see what's 32 over 5,000 you can
delete these zeros let's see 16 / 25
right that equals so 16 16 / 25 is equal
to four fifths to the end and we should
immediately well hopefully will
immediately right you'd recognize is
that sixteen is four squared and 25 is 5
squared so 16 / 25 is equal to 4 over 5
squared right four squared is 16 5
squared is 25 so n is equal to 22 years
and that is choice B
and 25 time for now we've got a couple
more problems i'll do the last three
problems in the next video i will see
you soon